on passe euh à notre second thème second
débat c'est un anniversaire que je vous
propose de célébrer celui des 30 ans du
référendum sur le traité européen de
Maastricht il a changé nos vies avec
l'euro évidemment comme monnaie unique
ouvert une ère nouvelle de la
construction de de l'Europe mais c'est
aussi le point de départ d'une fracture
politique qui s'élargit encore
aujourd'hui fort à sauvage
tritch ce nom résonne chez des milliers
d'Européens comme un acte fondateur de
la création de l'Union en février 1992
cette petite ville des Pays-Bas
accueille les représentants des 12
premiers États membres pour signer le
traité qui porte son nom
François Mitterrand décide de faire
ratifier le traité par référendum
Elizabeth Guigou est alors ministre
délégué chargé des Affaires européennes
il faut démocratiser le processus sinon
ça finira par éclater après le traité de
Rome en 1957 instituant la Communauté
économique européenne le traité de
Maastricht pose les jalons d'une monnaie
unique d'une banque centrale européenne
et de la libre circulation des capitaux
il crée aussi la citoyenneté européenne
désormais chaque citoyen peut choisir
son pays de résidence et circuler
librement au sein de l'UE a été un
véritable tournant dans l'histoire la
construction européenne à ce que marque
Maastricht 3 ans après la chute du mur
de Berlin qui a introduit véritablement
une rupture géopolitique en Europe c'est
véritablement d'ouvrir en fait vers un
acte 2 de la construction européenne
définissons une nouvelle vocation à la
construction européenne vocation
davantage politique pour compléter la
construction européenne uniquement par
le marché
introduit une rupture avec la vision
d'une Europe principalement économique
et crée de profondes divisions au sein
de la classe politique hexagonale ça
aussi transformer le paysage politique
car au clivage gauche-droite
traditionnelle ce superposer un clivage
monnaie unique ou maintient du franc et
plus largement pour suite de la
profondissement européen ou au contraire
retour à une Europe des nations au sens
le plus strict six mois après sa
signature le traité de Maastricht est
adopté de justesse par le peuple
français avec 51% des voix depuis son
clivage vont apparaître avec le traité
de Maastricht l'Europe la question
européenne entrait dans le droit commun
du débat démocratique et je crois qu'on
est pas sorti en fait de cette période
là pour ce qui concerne un pays comme la
France clairement
cet aspect en fait c'est encore renforcé
au milieu des années 2000 en 2005 lors
d'un autre référendum cette fois sur le
traité constitutionnel aujourd'hui en
2022 et on voit bien depuis 5 ans que le
match final de l'élection présidentielle
oppose en fait deux visions radicalement
différente de la construction européenne
et de la place de notre pays dans cette
construction 30 ans après la signature
du traité et la création de l'euro
Maastricht reste aujourd'hui un
événement fondateur de la construction
européenne l'épidémie de covid-19 et la
guerre en Ukraine montre que cette union
est plus que jamais d'actualité
et on revient donc sur cet anniversaire
avec Marion gaillard bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes docteur en histoire
spécialiste des questions
européennes Roger caoutchi bonsoir
ancien collaborateur et conseiller
politique de Philippe Seguin Guillaume
Durand bonsoir bien sûr heureux de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau journaliste la
Radio Classique vous aviez arbitré
évidemment le fameux débat Mitterrand
Seguin le 3 septembre 1992 et puis vous
publiez en cette rentrée des genoux sur
l'herbe c'est aux éditions bouquin ça ne
parle pas de Maastricht
mais je cite votre livre avec grand
plaisir avec nous également en
visioconférence bernardieta député
européen bonsoir bienvenue vous étiez
éditorialisé aux politiques sur France
Inter à l'époque et vous défendez
évidemment et on vous a déjà reçu sur ce
plateau l'Europe l'intégration
européenne Laetitia cruppa guitariste
politique toujours à mes côtés première
question à la fois simple et compliqué
que retenir de ce traité 30 ans après je
voudrais faire un homme si je le
rappelle vous voyez Louis ont porté de
justesse à peine plus de 51% Marion
gaillard c'est quoi moi spontanément je
vais dire la solidité de l'euro est-ce
que vous diriez ça vous aussi alors
Maastricht c'est effectivement la
transformation de la Communauté
économique européenne en Union
Européenne donc on passe comme ça a été
dit tout à l'heure par Thierry Chopin à
une Europe qui est plus politique c'est
l'euro bien évidemment avec la création
de l'Union économique et monétaire mais
sur le plan politique la mise en place
d'une politique étrangère à de sécurité
commune la mise en place d'une
coopération dans le domaine de la
justice et des affaires d'intérieur et
la citoyenneté européenne donc ça donne
à la construction européenne plus
d'ampleur et ça l'approfondie donc c'est
une étape supplémentaire dans
l'approfondissement de la construction
européenne quel bilan vous faites Roger
caoutchi 30 ans après pas le même
bien des choses aurait pu être faites
dans le cadre de l'Union européenne moi
un peu après Maastrich je suis devenu
député européen donc je suis pas un
anti-européen primaire loin de là
mais on a forcé le destin on a voulu
forcer les peuples on a forcé les
nations à passer d'un coup d'un seul à
une monnaie unique à passer d'un coup
d'un seul une bonne centrale européenne
l'idée c'était pas d'ailleurs chez ses
gains de s'opposer à l'Europe c'était de
dire faisons d'abord une monnaie commune
on verra plus tard s'il y a une monnaie
unique on a voulu forcer les portes en
disant c'est maintenant ou jamais le
résultat des courses c'est que 30 ans
après on se rend compte que on y est pas
parvenu et qu'aujourd'hui on paye en
boomerang le fait que beaucoup
d'état-nations et que beaucoup de
nations se disent est-ce que réellement
c'était la bonne solution alors il y a
eu des aménagements il y a eu des
avancées 30 ans de son pas restés avides
il y a eu beaucoup de traités d'accord
d'évolution même au sein de l'Union
européenne y compris au sein de la
Commission européenne qui a compris
qu'il fallait un peu de souplesse mais
je considère que on aurait dû faire un
autre Maastricht pour faire avancer la
construction européenne sans forcer les
peuples parce qu'à un moment ça revient
en boomant on va y revenir évidemment en
détail Guillaume durant le premier
souvenir qui vous revient de ce alors je
parle on parle du débat plus tard mais
de ce 20 septembre 92 le jour où le
résultat
vous avez 40 ans oui 70 aujourd'hui la
même semaine donc vous voyez c'est un
peu changé quand même dans ce plaisant
vous savez j'ai été élève d'histoire
donc j'avais une professeure brillante
comme notre invité
à l'époque quand on allait l'université
j'arrive à ma Street tout de suite on
nous expliquait que l'histoire était
faite en gros par les grands mouvements
de fou les basculements et c'était ça et
au fond c'était l'éducation des années
70 les hommes jouent un rôle et peu
importe sauf Louis XIV Napoléon et
évidemment le général de Gaulle n'avait
pas de statut de héros moi ce jour-là
j'ai vu un personnage qui avait François
Mitterrand
qui était face à quelqu'un que j'aimais
beaucoup Philippe Seguin
je l'ai vu comme je vous vois c'est à
dire un monsieur d'un certain âge
extrêmement malade qui était en train de
transformer son
utopie socialiste à il ne croyait que
moyennement vers la fin en Utopie
européenne et qui a un soir retourné le
pays donc je parle au nom des politiques
en général la statue du héros chez les
politiques et du rôle qu'il joue et
fondamentalement important ce gars n'a
pas perdu ce débat il a été impressionné
parce qu'il a vu dans les sous-sols
parce que Mitterrand était malade était
très malade il a été très républicain
plutôt que de pousser des hurlements en
disant je m'adresse à un homme malade il
s'est compensé d'une manière extrêmement
élégante
il a dit ce qu'il pensait mais il a pas
fait un scandale comment aurait pu le
faire par exemple Philippe de Villiers à
l'époque mais simplement et je parle
sous le contrôle de carucci j'ai fait
quand même à l'époque le tour de tous
ceux qui voulaient affronter Mitterrand
réponse 0 personne ne voulait y aller il
savait tous c'est vrai Roger ni Pasqua
ni de Villiers ne voulait aller
affronter Mitterrand cette affaire là
c'était impossible à moi on a même
envisagé que ce soit Jacques Calvet le
patron justement le grand patron de
l'automobile parce qu'il était adhérent
qui s'était opposé à Maastricht donc
vous avez vu un an de Peugeot à l'époque
on a vu là je ne rentre pas dans les
considérations avant qu'on parle
justement des conséquences qu'ils ont
évoqué on a vu un homme qui se retrouve
à l'agonie avec un peuple qui est dans
le nombre dans tous les thés dans le nom
à la fin du mois d'août il arrive sur le
plateau et trois heures plus tard ça a
changé et ça a basculé quand ça a changé
à très peu de voix mais ça a changé
Bernard Guetta qu'est-ce que vous un peu
la même question vous retenez quoi de
cette de cette date le fait que ce
traité fait rentrer l'Europe dans une
nouvelle ère
certainement mais ce que je retiens
surtout c'est que 30 ans après
premièrement la catastrophe que les
opposants à l'introduction de la monnaie
unique prédisée ne sait pas absolument
pas produit mais plus spectaculaire
encore les opposants les plus vigoureux
les plus bâtons à l'euro et bien
finalement
ont mis leur drapeau en poche regardez
Madame Le Pen au moment de la dernière
élection de l'avant-dernière excusez-moi
élection présidentielle bien elle disait
en dénonçant l'Union européenne comme
une prison des peuples elle disait qu'il
fallait sortir de l'euro et puis elle a
compris maintenant que cette idée non
seulement n'était pas populaire mais
était totalement impopulaire et que si
elle voulait rester dans la course et
bien il fallait qu'elle change
complètement de position sur l'euro et
qu'en vérité elle renonce à vouloir en
sortir regard ce qui se passe en Italie
avec l'extrême droite qui peut arriver
qui vraisemblablement si on en croit les
traités les traités excusez-moi les
sondages va arriver va arriver au
pouvoir dans 8 jours en Italie et bien
c'est extrême droite là aussi à renoncer
à toute idée de sortir de l'euro
aujourd'hui qui propose de sortir de
l'euro je ne le vois pas je ne vois pas
de force significative ou ou même faible
d'ailleurs qui proposerait cela et pour
une simple raison c'est que aujourd'hui
450 millions d'Européens ce sont
parfaitement adaptés à cette monnaie
unique qui symbolise l'unité de l'Europe
et l'incarne alors je voudrais continuer
on est à la fois dans les souvenirs et
c'est pour ça que ce débat est
passionnant c'est dans les leçons qu'on
peut en tirer 30 ans plus tard trois
décennies plus tard mais dans la partie
souvenir je me suis demandé pourquoi
François Mitterrand avait choisi la voie
du référendum regardez l'extrait de ce
documentaire Maastricht 30 ans après ce
sont Lionel Jospin et Hubert Védrines
qui témoignent les sondages laissaient
entendre que
le oui l'emporterait très largement et
donc du coup peut-être que François
Mitterrand reste les fins politiques
c'est dit oh bah si j'ai un succès dans
un référendum politiquement ça sur mieux
la deuxième partie du deuxième septennat
en quelque sorte et donc il s'est laissé
tenter
comment s'assurer que la légitimité est
complète et que le futur traité
sanctuarisait je pense que cette
question est présente dans l'esprit de
François mitter avant même qu'il conclut
donc je vais faire un référendum Marion
gaillard donc il y a cette intuition qui
sera démenti par la campagne que le
référendum va passer facilement dans
quel climat il se déroule elle se
déroule pardon cette campagne la
campagne se déroule dans un climat quand
même qui est mauvais pour l'exécutif
puisqu'on a une chute de popularité très
très importante depuis même 1991 donc
clairement le climat n'est pas bon je
rejoins ce qui a été dit à la fois par
Lionel Jospin parce que il y a sans
doute la volonté de semer un peu la
zizanie à droite notamment finalement ça
la semé à gauche aussi donc c'est un peu
l'arroser arrosée mais aussi la question
qui évoque Hubert Védrine de la
légitimité parce que si on se souvient
de ce qui s'est passé ensuite en 2002
juste avant 2002 au moment du passage à
l'euro il y avait une pression
extrêmement forte qui était exercée sur
le président Jacques Chirac de la part
des antimastricht pour faire un deuxième
référendum vous soyez pour dire bah
maintenant on y est il faut refaire un
référendum et Jacques Chirac c'est
appuyé sur la légitimité du référendum
de 92 pour ne pas refaire un référendum
donc je crois que oui il y a cette idée
de sanctuariser un résultat et je suis
désolé on n'a pas été contre les peuples
on n'a pas forcé le destin ce référendum
a apporté 51% de oui c'est serré mais
c'est la démocratie donc on n'a pas
violé les peuples en faisant
maastrichtodon dans d'autres pays parce
que c'était ça en plus l'enjeu
des opting out c'est à dire le fait de
ne pas participer à un certain nombre de
politiques notamment l'euro mais comme
le disait Bernard Guetta aujourd'hui
plus personne n'assume politiquement
l'idée de sortir de la zone euro donc on
a quand même un bilan qui n'est pas
parfait parce que rien n'est parfait
dans l'Union européenne loin de là mais
on a l'euro qui a survécu à la crise des
années 2010 et une zone euro qui a
montré sa capacité d'adaptation quand
même décidé au delà et par de là et sans
prendre en compte le peuple c'était la
ligne de Philippe Seguin c'était la
Ligue des opposants justement à ce
traité de Maastricht et eux qui
voulaient et me semble-t-il ils ont
forcé François Mitterrand à faire ce
référendum c'est eux qui vous laisser
référendum parce que je pense que puis
ensuite on va écouter un extrait de d'un
discours très marquant de Philippe la
réalité c'est qu'on est en septembre 92
on est six mois avant les législatives
de mars 93 on sait très bien que la
droite remonte dans tous les sondages
qu'elle est donnée largement gagnée
pendant ce 93 donc François Mitterrand
essaye je partage tout à fait ce qu'a
dit Guillaume durant tout à l'heure moi
j'avais accompagné Philippe Séguin on
avait répété le débat mais quand il est
revenu d'avoir vu Mitterrand me direz je
peux pas il y a que des infirmières
autour de lui et je lui dis attendez je
suis désolé mais
faut y aller quand même et en réalité
vous avez raison il a pas changé de
discours mais c'était constamment ça
m'en défou à côté c'était constamment
monsieur le Président de la République
oui monsieur le Président de la
République on se disait hallucinant on a
besoin d'un petit garçon en face du
président et en fait surtout qu'il a été
d'abord remarqué une sorte de France
et j'entends bien ce qui est dit mais
pardon de vous dire quand on dit ah bah
personne veut sortir de l'euro oui bah
une fois que vous avez mis en place tous
les systèmes les gens sont inquiets
n'ont pas envie d'un tout de tout casser
mais enfin est-ce qu'on a créé un esprit
européen dans toute l'Europe depuis 30
ans le brexit on y reviendra évidemment
peut-être un mot l'état de santé de
François Mitterrand avant d'écouter
Philippe Sega est-ce que à un moment
vous êtes dit non non mais
en tant comme animateur comme animateur
est-ce qu'à un moment vous êtes dit ce
débat n'aura pas lieu on va pas pouvoir
le l'organiser non non moi je me
souviens simplement au mois d'août j'ai
vu deux trois fois au mois d'août je
l'ai vu une fois et il m'a dit
écoutez si jamais c'est le nom moi j'ai
une chance de m'en sortir vous aucune à
bientôt et donc je l'ai revu le jour du
débat mais j'ai su par témoignage après
notamment par Roger Hanin que dans les
jours qui précédaient il avait été
extrêmement malade extrêmement malade il
était resté alité pour préparer
justement ce débat il n'avait pas du
tout préparé non je crois pour revenir à
Squeezie tout à l'heure mais je veux pas
me répéter qu'il était porté cette sur
cette affaire là pour des raisons qui
sont assez évidentes c'est que ce qu'on
avait vécu en 80 c'était à cet espoir
que beaucoup partagé notamment sur le
plan économique qui était une aberration
et qu'il fallait bien essayer de
terminer une carrière politique sur une
utopie qui soit une utopie positive donc
on AB système de socialisme au sens du
programme commun mais on va vers
l'Europe parce que c'est un espoir à la
fois pour ceux qui vivent en Europe et
en même temps pour la jeunesse alors
comme promis un extrait de ce discours
de Philippe Seguin on est le 5 mai 1992
c'est à l'Assemblée nationale donc on
est six mois avant enfin 4 mois avant le
débat dans ton dans ton parlait
Assemblée nationale un discours qui a
marqué les esprits on a choisi vous avez
choisi d'ailleurs Laetitia un extrait
assez long ça dure une minute regardez
le projet de loi viol de façon flagrante
le principe suivant lequel la
souveraineté nationale est inaliénable
et imprescriptible ainsi que le principe
de la séparation des pouvoirs
en dehors duquel une société doit être
considérée comme dépourvu de
constitution
il existe en effet au-dessus même de la
Charte constitutionnelle
des droits naturels
inaliénables et sacrées à savoir pour
nous les droits de l'homme et du citoyen
tels qu'ils ont été définis par la
Déclaration de 1789
et quand l'article 3 de la Constitution
du 4 octobre 1958
rappelle que la souveraineté nationale
appartient au peuple
il ne fait que reconnaître le pacte
originel qui est depuis plus de 200 ans
le fondement de notre État de droit bon
je vais être transparent avec vous c'est
pas tout à fait l'extrait que vous aviez
choisi Laetitia mais c'est pas grave ça
ça arrive vous allez pouvoir vous
reprendre dans votre voix certains des
mots employés par Philippe seguineux ce
soir-là parce que vous y voyez et c'est
intéressant les germes d'une fracture
défiance en tout cas entre les gouvernés
et les gouvernants oui je vais y aller
carrément il a mis le verre dans le
fruit avec sa communication il a posé la
graine de la défiance du peuple parce
que dans l'extrait qu'effectivement vous
n'avez pas vu mais que je vais vous
citer parce qu'il y a des mots qui sont
vraiment très forts ils parlent d'une
oligarchie qui en catimini prend des
décisions au nom des peuples sans en
avoir reçu le mandat dans le secret des
cabinets dans la pénombre des
commissions tout cela dans une
conspiration du silence alors je sais
bien que ce discours a été encensé
notamment aujourd'hui dans Le Figaro
parent regaino qui était une des plumes
de ce discours mais à l'époque le but je
l'avais dit c'était de forcer François
Mitterrand à faire un référendum et ça a
été réussi mais c'est tout de même
insensé quand on réécoute ces mots 30
ans plus tard je trouve que c'est
pyromane parce que ce sont exactement
les termes qu'utilisent aujourd'hui ce
qu'on appelle les populistes l'extrême
droite si vous voulez en tout cas les
populistes qui veulent renverser les
élites en gros on est dans plus dans un
discours de peuple dépassé et de peuples
qui essaient pion d'une oligarchie et
donc et disons qu'il serait des pions
dans ce Maastricht dont il n'aurait
aucune alors il y a quand même là il y a
quand même dans son discours un constat
qui est repris par beaucoup de gens
depuis l'après dominance de l'Allemagne
la perte de souveraineté des nations oui
mais qui en profite aujourd'hui qui en
profite de ce discours est-ce que c'est
Emmanuel Macron qui a défendu cette idée
de la souveraineté de la France pendant
toute la campagne potentiel où est-ce
que son sang les extrêmes encore une
fois et les populistes est-ce que ça a
été traité dans les médias aujourd'hui
ou c'est de 3 grands mystères du jour
quasiment rien alors il y a eu donc le
Figaro dans les pages des bas la semaine
dernière la Une de mariage qu'il a
vraiment traité dans ses pages rien dans
les matinales radio et télé j'ai pas
fait une veille média
classique je n'ai pas écouté radio
classique mais alors vraiment ça a été
fait à minima par tout le monde et
pourtant je le répète les mots de
Philippe Séguin ce que je vous ai dit
illustré à mon avis un tournant dans
l'histoire politique de notre pays un
homme du système je vous rappelle qu'il
était député RPR des Vosges qui
fustigeait la doxa qui a posé finalement
le OUI à ce traité de Maastricht donc un
homme du système qui dénonce la
conspiration du silence en 1992 il y a
de quoi réfléchir Roger qu'est-ce que ça
vous inspire
européen bien m'en a pris pour mieux
comprendre le système de l'intérieur
très clairement alors ça change un peu
depuis une dizaine d'années pas parce
qu'il y a eu Maastricht mais parce que
l'échec du référendum de 2005 a mis
quand même un peu la puce à l'oreille a
bien beaucoup de responsables européens
mais très clairement franchement
allez j'employé les grands mots la
techno structure de Bruxelles avait tous
les pouvoirs moi quand j'étais députés
européens on nous expliquait vous êtes
gentil vous appartenez à la majorité PPE
etc du Parlement européen mais en fait
ne vous fatiguez pas les commissaires
européens ont déjà transmis au groupe à
l'administration etc on avait
l'impression d'être dessaisi on était là
pour voter ça oui mais on était décisif
du vrai pouvoir de débat du vrai pouvoir
de vote et à un moment
un moment clairement on se dit qu'est-ce
que c'est que cette structure où les
choses ne sont pas démocratiques alors
je suis désolé il y a eu un référendum
en France
51%. voilà les choses sont dites mais je
conteste pas le résultat du référendum
il y a eu un vote il y a eu un vote mais
d'ailleurs Philippe Sagan n'a jamais
contesté mais on peut se dire que à
terme cette construction imposée ne
pouvait pas plaire on pouvait très bien
faire un masque différent en 1992 on
aurait peut-être pas eu aujourd'hui les
pays d'Europe de l'Est qui secoue le
cocotier aujourd'hui le Royaume-Uni qui
est sorti aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
Georgia Meloni dit rien sur l'euro mais
regardez écoutez les critiques sur le
fonctionnement européen partout où on en
est de l'armée européenne nulle part où
on en est un certain nombre de
politiques européennes qu'on espérait
nulle paroisse qu'on a mis de la force
c'est en rien complotiste il dénonçait
le fait que la technostructure
l'emportait sur les parlementaires lui
elle est beaucoup plus loin en vrai si
vous regardez le discours en entier à un
moment il dit l'abais c'est eux vous la
voulez la Banque centrale européenne la
Banque centrale européenne pardon mais
en réalité si vous voulez une politique
unitaire en Europe il faut un
gouvernement économique de l'Europe pas
seulement une banque avec pas de
gouvernement au dessus est-ce qu'on est
allé vers un gouvernement européen non
non alors ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a
une ligne de démarcation politique qui
n'est en cette année à l'occasion de se
référer un homme je vais citer originaux
dans le les pages des bananes on vous
parliez
tout à l'heure donc quelques voix fortes
ont commencé à s'élever au sein de ce
qu'on a appelé les parties de
gouvernement s'est bien passent quoi au
RPR chevet de mon PS Philippe de
Villiers c'est avec Maastricht que la
question européenne devient un sujet
structurant de la vie politique que le
projet fédéralisme revient en force
comme l'objectif inavoué mais constant
de ce que l'on appelle les de la
construction européenne c'est un moment
charnière Bernard Guetta vous nous
écoutez depuis tout à l'heure je voulais
revenir évidemment vers vous c'est
effectivement une nouvelle ligne de
démarcation qui est kiné à ce moment-là
et qui d'ailleurs met en difficulté les
partis politiques traditionnels qui vont
un peu le essayer de laisser la
poussière sous le tapis est-ce que vous
diriez ça non je crois pas vraiment
moi ce qui me frappe
c'est exactement le contraire de ce que
vient de décrire monsieur caoutchi quand
on est aujourd'hui au Parlement européen
ce qui est ce qui est mon cas qu'est-ce
qu'on constate on constate que le tabou
car il en avait un féroce contre l'idée
même d'une défense commune européenne
est totalement tombée on constate que le
tabou sur les emprunts européens communs
pour investir en commun et totalement
tomber 750 milliards d'euros ont été
empruntés en commun par les 27 pays de
l'Union européenne pour investir en
commun troisième point on constate
aujourd'hui avec l'agression russe
contre l'Ukraine que l'unité politique
de l'Union européenne et plus solide que
jamais parce qu'il n'y a qu'un seul pays
10 millions d'habitants la petite de
monsieur orbagne qui renaquent tous les
autres suivent et suivent la même
politique qui est de s'opposer à
l'agression contre l'Ukraine par des
fournitures d'âme et par un soutien
financier évidemment à l'Ukraine donc
quand on est à Bruxelles qu'est-ce qu'on
voit on voit un formidable progrès des
tests qui avaient toujours été celle de
la France sur l'Union européenne à
savoir qu'il faut aller vers une Europe
puissance vers une Union européenne qui
soit un acteur politique de la scène
internationale vers une Europe qui
investissent en commun qui est des
politiques industrielles communes et
bien c'est exactement ce qui se passe et
quand je repense à toutes les
descriptions apocalyptiques de ce
qu'elle est entraîné l'introduction de
la monnaie unique je ne peux que sourire
et quand je repense à ce qui se disait
au moment du référendum perdu celui-là
sur le projet de Constitution bien
souvenons-nous monsieur Fabius paraît
exemple tisé que il fallait refuser de
graver le libéralisme dans le marbre
bien écoutez
en fait de libéralisme l'Allemagne et la
France qui convaincre les 25 autres
partenaires de l'Union européenne encore
une fois d'emprunter 750 milliards
d'euros pour investir en commun ce n'est
pas exactement Margaret Thatcher ce
n'est pas exactement le libéralisme qui
soi-disant allait être gravé dans le
marbre alors tout ce qu'on a entendu au
moment de Maastricht référendum gagné au
moment de 2005 le référendum perdu sur
le projet de Constitution pardonnez-moi
de le dire c'était faux cela relevé
d'une erreur fondamentale et ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui le prouve bon on n'a
pas l'impression que vous vivez dans la
même Europe que tous les deux
Marion gaillard il y a dans ce que nous
dit Bernard Guetta la référence aux deux
dernières crises d'ailleurs qui ne sont
pas toutes seulement terminés la crise
covid et la guerre en
Ukraine qu'est-ce qu'elle révèle de la
solidité ou du fonctionnement de
l'Europe pour vous elle révèle à la fois
les forces et les faiblesses d'une
certaine manière alors je suis
entièrement d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit ça vous étonnera pas par
Bernard Guetta et j'aurais aimé pouvoir
rebondir sur ce mythe du déficit
démocratique de l'Union européenne et
creusée sur la soi-disant oligarchie qui
n'existe pas parce que les décisions ne
sont pas prises par la Commission
européenne elles sont prises par le
Conseil des ministres et depuis
Maastricht Amsterdam et surtout Nice
elles sont prises par le Parlement
européen donc tout ça justement
de l'Europe aujourd'hui
la Commission européenne a un pouvoir de
proposition
donc ce n'est pas elle qui vote les lois
elle les propose par ailleurs elle est
investie membre par membre par le
Parlement européen c'est à dire comme ce
qu'on avait pour le gouvernement
français sous la Quatrième République
que je sache aujourd'hui le ou la
première ministre en France et les
ministres ne sont pas investis par
l'Assemblée nationale personne ne crie
au loup donc finalement la légitimité
démocratique de la commission elle est
validée par le Parlement européen ce qui
n'est même pas le cas de notre
gouvernement en France donc il faut
quand même rester dans la réalité de ce
qui se passe je ne dis pas que tout va
bien encore une fois la construction
européenne comme son nom l'indique c'est
une construction donc on est dans un
processus chacune des étapes n'est pas
satisfaisante elle n'est satisfaisante
ni pour les souverainistes ni pour les
fédéralistes mais progressivement on
avance alors j'entends bien que on
n'avance pas dans le sens que
souhaiterait mon voisin ça j'ai bien
compris et c'est tout à fait votre votre
droit parce que je crois je vous en prie
au fil et justement l'Union européenne
ne vous oblige pas à adhérer à penser
les les traiter sont ratifiés par les
États membres à partir de ce moment là
les peuples ne sont pas violés mais pour
répondre à votre question l'Ukraine et
là et le covid ça montre à la fois les
faiblesses et les forces les forces
parce qu'effectivement comme ça a été
souligné il y a une capacité
d'adaptation on a réussi à sortir des
dogmes des traités pour s'en d'été en
commun on a réussi à livrer des armes à
l'Ukraine ce qui était impensable il y a
encore quelques années donc ça veut dire
que l'Union européenne justement elle
est malléable elle s'adapte à la
situation Maastricht c'était une
adaptation aussi à la sortie de la
guerre froide d'une certaine manière et
là ce qu'on vient de vivre avec le covid
ou l'Ukraine c'est une adaptation un
nouveau contexte géopolitique d'un autre
côté bien entendu loin de moi l'idée de
dire que tout va pour le mieux dans le
meilleur des mondes c'est à dire que le
covid c'est 750 milliards d'euros il en
aurait peut-être fallu un peu plus un
peu plus vite l'Ukraine il faudrait
évidemment en faire plus et le problème
de l'Union européenne on est 27 faut des
compromis on ne viole pas les pubs donc
il faut des compromis et donc c'est
toujours un peu trop un peu trop tard et
pas assez voilà ça c'est une vraie
faiblesse Guillaume durant peut-être un
regard sur moi je reprends la question
où je posais à Bernard Guetta sur le
fait que les partis politiques
traditionnels on va dire partie
socialiste ou
RPR à l'époque ils ont fait comme si de
rien n'était après ce référendum est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ça c'est à
dire qu'il y avait une Bastière qui
avait une rupture quand même profonde
qui s'était exprimée en interne dans
chacun de ces parties mais on a fait
comme si moi j'ai l'impression là je
reviens aux études je pense que
l'économie quand même à une fonction
fondamentale d'influence sur la
politique et je lisais récemment le
livre de Daniel Cohen qui s'appelle Homo
Numericus et j'ai un souvenir parce que
je ne peux que raconter à mon grand âge
des souvenirs c'est l'affaire des gilets
jaunes et du restaurant célèbre des
Champs-Élysées qui brûle qu'est-ce qu'on
voit voyez les gens dans la rue qui
protestent
il voit dans ce restaurant brûlé qui
pourrait le symbole d'un certain type de
pouvoir politique que connaît bien
carucci d'un président de la République
et jubile qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils
sortent ce que j'ai dans la poche qui
est là et il filme en fait le désarroi
que nous connaissons actuellement il est
pas lié au pouvoir d'avant ni à celui
d'aujourd'hui ni à la Commission
européenne il est lié à la désagréation
totale de la société par les sociétés de
la tech internationales qui sont en
train et qu'on n'est pas du tout à ma
question
pourquoi ils n'ont pas répondu à ces
questions là parce que en fait à cette
époque là naissait Apple ne sait
Facebook et que le grand bouleversement
vous savez combien Facebook à payer
snapchat à cette époque là environ ils
ont payé 19 milliards une boîte où il y
avait 55 salariés c'est ça faisait 335
millions pour chaque dollars pour chaque
salarié les gens n'ont pas vu venir ça
et alors allez expliquer à des gens qui
sont complètement accro à ça que celui
ou celle où les sociétés sont en train
de désagréger leur propre société ce
sont justement des objets qui font
partie de leur vie quotidienne et
l'autre ne veulent pas se passer que
cherchent-ils toute la journée des
bouquets nicers et les partis politiques
c'est pour ça que je reviens à la
question les partis politiques ont mis
un temps fou à se rendre compte de cette
situation qui n'était pas de leur fait
et qui d'ailleurs n'est pas simplement
un fait vous allez dire établi d'une
manière
satisfaisante aux États-Unis puisque
c'est ces sociétés latex sont plutôt
démocrates et on a eu vous savez Trump
qui était très opposé à ces sociétés
pendant des années ça n'a pas changé du
tout et le pouvoir
Guetta peut le raconter la bataille de
Thierry Breton pour pouvoir essayer de
faire payer des impôts à ces sociétés
sans qu'il les paie dans de la Loire et
puis une bataille homérique qui dure
depuis des années
alors vous l'avez évoqué le dogme des
traités je voudrais qu'on revienne
là-dessus tout de suite et je propose à
terme traduit de de nous rejoindre parce
que
rebonsoir tams cette idée de l'esprit de
Maastricht c'est revenu dans le discours
de la présidente de la Commission
européenne Ursula wanderline dans son
discours de rentrée là ce mois de
septembre dernier le 14 septembre elle
s'exprime lors de l'un de ses exercices
annuels obligés le discours sur l'état
de l'Union où elle expose en clair son
programme pour l'année à venir et une
phrase à retenue l'attention sur ma
Street bien sûr écoutez
redécouvrons l'esprit de Maastricht la
stabilité la croissance ne serait allée
que de perdre voilà c'est court à
redécouvrir Maastricht pour revoir la
gouvernance économique de l'Europe voilà
en substance ce cas déclaré sur
l'avant-dernière en clair se rappeler
les critères de convergence décidé alors
pour que les États membres puissent
réduire les disparités entre leurs
économies l'obligation pour eux de
maintenir le déficit en dessous de 3% du
PIB et la dette publique à un niveau
inférieur ou égal à 60% du PIB des
règles qui ont inspiré le pacte de
stabilité de croissance des verrous qui
ont volé en éclat avec la pandémie de
covid qui n'est pas finie et tous les
mécanismes exceptionnels de soutien à
l'économie qui en ont découlé quelle
réaction à cette à cette déclaration
d'Ursula wanderline alors naturellement
l'opposition de gauche à peu gouter
cette référence écouter l'euro député
portugaise Mariza Mathias a invité de
l'émission ici l'Europe sur Public Sénat
ne fonctionnent pas et c'est pourquoi
nous avons eu besoin des suspendre le
pack stabiliser stabilité équation
pendant l'actualité et même chez les
alliés de cela vanderleyen le soutien
n'est pas total Fabienne Keller député
européenne Renaissance réunion en
anglais le nom du groupe au Parlement
européen tempèrent les ardeurs vers un
trop strict retour à l'orthodoxie
budgétaire une
philosophie de rigueur budget enfin de
gestion budgétaire saine plutôt mais
celle-ci ne peut pas s'appuyer sur des
critères anciens qui ont 30 ans
Maastricht il y a 30 ans
il nous faut définir ce qui semble
efficace pour encourager à une gestion
saine des finances publiques parce qu'on
y a tous intérêt mais sans fragiliser la
reprise économique oui elle s'est
reprise à Fabienne Keller l'actualité ce
n'est pas la rigueur mais plutôt la
crainte d'une récession en Europe avec
l'influence que nous connaissons porter
par la crise de l'énergie et pour
terminer on en est où aujourd'hui de
l'application de ces critères de
Maastricht alors pour l'instant
l'application de ces critères est
suspendu jusqu'à fin 2023 les européens
ne veulent pas commettre la même erreur
qu'après la crise de 2008 ils avaient
alors resserrer les taux trop vite et
avait donc tué la reprise reste
qu'aujourd'hui certains parmi les 27
notamment l'Europe du Nord l'Allemagne
veulent un retour à l'orthodoxie
budgétaire la commission elle ne va pas
aussi loin mais elle demande au pays les
plus endettés de comment ça réduire leur
dette elle demande à la France de
réformer son système de retraite elle va
revoir les critères du pacte de
stabilité et de croissance objective
c'est voir comment aussi financer les
investissements pour tirer l'économie
européenne vers le haut ça promet des
débattendus et c'est prévu pour cet
automne merci Tam traduit pour les
chroniques de la rédaction dans cette
émission aujourd'hui Marion gaillard
c'est un bras de fer qui démarre sur
cette question des 3% oui sans doute
alors effectivement ça a été le dogme
pendant très très longtemps et là je je
pense que je serai davantage d'accord
avec mon voisin c'est à dire que oui
Maastricht a mis en place un certain
nombre de règles contre lesquelles on
peut
s'insurger en fonction de la nécessité
de certains pays de dépasser ces
critères il faut toujours avoir en tête
encore une fois que les critères qui
étaient posés sont le reflet d'une
idéologie politique ou d'un équilibre
idéologique entre les 12 pays à l'époque
et il faut évidemment les faire évoluer
ils ont évolué on les a comme ça étaient
très bien dit complètement fait voler en
éclat maintenant il y a un certain
nombre de pays et de gouvernement selon
les tendances politiques aussi qui
veulent revenir à ces critères très
stricts pour l'instant je pense pas
personnellement pour le coup que ce soit
vraiment le moment de s'exciter sur les
3% parce que on y arrivera pas
objectivement et surtout sur la dette
avec la situation actuelle de la guerre
en Ukraine donc certains poussent là sur
l'Allemagne c'est plus mitigé parce que
au sein de la coalition il y a quand
même une différence très importante
entre le Parti libéral qui veut revenir
au sacro-sainte de stabilité et aux 3%
et quand même les verres et le SPD qui
penchent plutôt pour une souplesse
encore quelques temps donc on verra les
équilibres à l'intérieur de la coalition
allemande ensuite les pays du Nord oui
ils vont rester sur ce créneau là mais
on est 27 et il y a aussi quand même des
forces et notamment en France qui
poussent et au Portugal en Espagne pour
que on ait une souplesse encore un petit
peu mais je suis un peu étonnée
effectivement de cette partie du
discours de la présidente de la
commission c'est pas toujours le moment
mais aucune classe politique n'est
exempte de défaut et donc la classe
politique européenne non plus
la question qui on va terminer là-dessus
nous reste un peu moins de 5 minutes
Roger CAO dessus de de l'extension
jusqu'où l'Europe doit-elle grandir moi
j'ai entendu j'étais assez surpris de
cette déclaration de du chancelier
allemand il y a quelques jours qui
plaidait pour un élargissement au pays
des Balkans occidentaux alors l'Ukraine
on sait où on en est Moldavie Géorgie il
parle d'une union VPN de 30 ou 36 déjà
la conviction qu'elle change c'est la
zone d'influence allemande c'est normal
que que l'Allemagne cherche à faire
entrer plus facilement les Balkans qui
sont on le sait bien mais
en vérité ça se fera pas on voit bien le
mal qu'on a avec certains pays
balkaniques commencez par la Serbie qui
sont en phase d'instruction depuis des
années mais que ça n'avance pas et c'est
pas ou à l'Ukraine
attendons de voir qu'il va la faire
entrer dans quelles conditions non la
vérité c'est que moi je suis pas du tout
anti-européen loin de là mais l'Europe
doit se poser des questions et il suffit
pas de se dire vive l'Europe pour que ça
marche quand on voit on me dit
Maastricht c'est merveilleux bah la
preuve c'est que Maastricht n'est pas
appliquée le 3% n'est pas appliqué le
60% n'est pas appliqué et c'était les
fondements de la monnaie unique ce qui
veut dire qu'on a fragilisé la monnaie
unique et on n'a pas de gouvernement
économique donc tout ça est très bien et
tout le monde dit ah ben il faut pas
toucher moi je m'en fiche
personnellement je suis plutôt
pro-européen et pour une Europe forte
mais il faut des garanties il faut que
ça bouge il faut que ça avance et il
faut qu'on se dise l'Europe est une
vraie puissance quand on voit ce qui se
passe en Ukraine c'est bien de dire en
dehors de la Hongrie tout le monde livre
des armes on a l'impression d'être pas
mal à la remorque des États-Unis d'une
OTAN qu'on avait tous critiqué parce que
c'était pas assez européen mais
maintenant on s'empresse de tous dire
vive l'OTAN et puis soyez partout donc
il y a un problème c'est pas seulement
la conception c'est cette puissance
européenne qui aujourd'hui ne marque pas
les peuples et housse forcément il va y
avoir des remises en cause moi je suis
totalement opposé à toutes sorties de
l'Europe à toutes sorties de l'euro à
tout ce qu'on voudra parce que je
considère qu'il faut avancer ensemble la
France seule n'est plus en situation de
s'imposer sur les internationale
elle existe cette identité là
n'est pas aussi évident de partout
pardon quand le Royaume-Uni sort de
l'Europe
comme par hasard l'identité européenne a
disparu au Royaume-Uni quand on dit un
certain nombre de choses en Italie en
Espagne au Portugal en France même si on
veut pas sortir de l'Europe par crainte
parce qu'on considère qu'il faut une
puissance véritable est-ce qu'il y a une
adhésion au phénomène européen oui si ça
protège mais si ça ne protège pas
suffisamment dans les années qui
viennent il y aura des remises pour
terminer je vous Bernard Guetta qui fait
signe depuis tout à l'heure vous lui
prendre la parole à vous le mot de la
conclusion
pour vous dire une chose je crois qu'il
est vraiment eu un énorme malentendu sur
le sens de la phrase que vous avez cité
de Madame vanderleyen le la croix la
stabilité la croissance vont de paix ce
que dit Madame vandereyenne à ce
moment-là c'est qu'on ne peut pas
privilégier le respect de la stabilité
déstabilitée budgétaire et monétaire
qu'il faut au contraire aujourd'hui se
soucier de la croissance et que sans
croissance ignora pas de stabilité et il
y a en ce moment un changement complet
dans l'Union européenne on vient de le
rappeler en disant que les critères de
Maastricht étaient suspendus jusqu'à fin
2023 excusez-moi les critères de
Maastricht qui étaient effectivement
complètement absurde et dont je n'ai
jamais été partisan et bien sont en
train de se casser la figure et on est
en train
revenir à des politiques beaucoup plus
kedienne à des politiques beaucoup plus
d'investissement d'État à des politiques
d'emprunt aussi à des politiques de
développement et non pas du tout de
respect crispé de critères qui n'avaient
effectivement aucune valeur ou très peu
de valeur en tout cas je crois
véritablement qu'on se trompe
complètement de lecture et puis encore
un dernier mot allez regarder le dernier
Euro baromètre qui a été publié
il y a une dizaine de jours jamais les
opinions européennes y compris en France
n'ont fait autant confiance aux
institutions européennes et beaucoup
plus qu'aux institutions nationales
là-dessus merci les gens perçoit merci
parce que les gens Bernard l'émission
est terminée merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'y avoir participé Guillaume je
rappelle le titre de votre livre deux
noms sur l'herbe publié aux éditions
bouquins l'histoire de l'art un peu
déjanté c'est ça oui je pourrais vous
raconter l'histoire d'Edouard Manet mais
je pense pas que ce soit idiot
malheureusement notre foi ce thème là
merci beaucoup
bonne soirée à toutes et à tous sur
Public Sénat votre prochain rendez-vous
politique c'est dans la matinale c'est
Claude malurey le président du groupe
Les Indépendants ici au Sénat qui sera
face à Oriane Mancini belle soirée